[APPLAUSE]
Yeah!
Huh?
Oh, calm down.
Thank you all very
much for coming along
for an exciting
evening of mathematics.
My name is Matt Parker.
I used to be a
maths teacher, which
is why I know that person is on
their phone while I'm talking.
Honestly.
[LAUGHTER]
Unbelievable.
Once a teacher,
always a teacher.
So can you all hear
me adequately loud,
amplified through
the microphone?
Excellent.
People at the top,
we're all happy?
Marvellous.
Right, so the plan
for tonight, as Peter
very kindly said in
his introduction--
and then went home.
Oh, that's a big vote of
confidence in tonight's talk.
As he very kindly
said, I do a wide range
of things involving
promoting mathematics or just
generally trying to
get more people more
excited about maths.
And I do things
like YouTube videos,
which is where I suspect
the vast majority
of the young people
know me from.
And I do BBC Radio 4,
which is the rest of you.
So I cover the whole spectrum.
And so I recently wrote
a book, Humble Pi.
And I'd written one
book previously called
Things to Make and Do in
the Fourth Dimension, which,
as was mentioned in
the introduction,
is currently the second most
viewed video on the RI channel,
despite the fact it's
all abstract mathematics.
And I figure tonight, with
some applied mathematics,
I'm taking number one.
So I wrote the first book.
And Penguin, the publishers,
were like, would you
like to write a second book?
And the problem with
Things to Make and Do
in the Fourth Dimension is, even
though I was incredibly proud
of it, and even though it sold
very well for a maths book,
it sold average for a book,
which is great, right?
Average is I'm
above 50% of books.
I'm very happy with that.
But Penguin don't care
what's in the book.
They could publish another
celebrity cookbook or anything.
I mean, that's the
one option, actually.
And so I had to convince
them it was a good decision
to publish a book
about mathematics.
And so I suggested to them I
could write a book all about
my favourite
mathematics mistakes,
which is where Humble Pi--
A Comedy of Maths
Errors came about.
And they liked that, because
people like tales of disaster.
They like stories of
things going wrong.
They enjoy laughing
at other people.
I've made a career of being
on the receiving end of that.
And they said, yes,
write that book.
That's great.
People who aren't
specifically maths
nerds, which is their
polite way of describing
my target demographic--
people will still enjoy
reading these stories.
And my ulterior motive was, by
showing examples of where maths
goes wrong in everything
from finance, engineering,
statistics, medicine,
you name it,
I can show-- it's an excuse
to talk about the maths that's
required for these areas
of our modern society.
And so obviously, maths
works pretty flawlessly
most of the time, so
much so that most people
have no idea how dependent
we are on mathematics.
And people often don't
value maths for that reason.
So I thought, this
is a great excuse
to just talk about
all the places maths
is used, but by using things
going wrong as my way in.
And actually, because I
used to be a maths teacher--
actually, give me a cheer.
Any maths teachers in?
[WEAK CHEER]
Hiding at the top,
not sounding exciting.
It's the end of
half term, isn't it?
Right, OK, there you are.
So I used to be a
maths teacher, just
like the fine people cowering
at the top of the room.
And then I left teaching.
But I still remembered how a lot
of young people-- because when
you were at school, you were
forced to do maths, right?
When you're forced to
do it, a other people
perceive mathematics
as the subject
where you have to get it right.
Getting the right
answer is everything.
It's the be all, end
all of mathematics.
And as a teacher, you
know that that's not
always strictly true, right?
Maths is about trying
something and getting it wrong,
and then trying it
again and hopefully
getting it less wrong,
and then more wrong.
And hopefully it converges
in on the minimal amount
of wrong possible.
But it's a long, slow process
of not understanding it and not
doing it well.
And it's always
very disappointing
when students, or
even people in--
standard-issue humans are afraid
to try some maths because they
think if they don't
get the right answer,
they haven't done it correctly.
And that's not true.
If you get the wrong
answer, you may still
be correct in your
trying it, right?
Mathematics is about learning
and teaching your brain
how to think.
And so I thought, how can I
bring that approach to what
will otherwise just be a random
collection of maths mistakes
that haven't got
any real meaning?
And I started with an
inspirational poster
that I had when I was a teacher.
And inspirational
posters are the staple
of the teaching world.
It's what you decorate
your classroom with.
And this was one of my
absolute favourites.
They you are--
education works best
when all the parts are working.
Now, let me just break
this down for you.
So you've got cogs representing
students, teachers,
and parents.
The trouble is, when that
big cog on the right,
which represents
students-- if that rotates,
let's say, clockwise, because
it meshes with teachers,
teachers have to
rotate anti-clockwise.
That's all very nice.
But neither of them
are going anywhere,
because parents are jamming
up the whole system.
[LAUGHS]
Surprisingly more applause from
the teachers than the parents.
Surprisingly accurate poster,
in my humble experience.
And then obviously,
people just haven't
thought through the geometry
of this situation, right?
If you have cogs,
they have to go
clockwise, anti-clockwise,
clockwise, anti-clockwise.
So when Manchester were
unveiling their new approach
to public transport, they went
with the classic three-cog
making the city work together,
although people did point
out and proceed to render
in 3D that that's just
this one point of view.
Possibly, from the
side, it's fine.
It's like, well played.
Well played.
If all you see is this, you
don't-- look, that's deep.
They were thinking-- they
were several steps ahead,
until I saw an article where
President Trump in the United
States was negotiating the North
American Free Trade Agreement.
And when that was
put in the newspapers
to show how all the working
parts of North America
should be moving
in unison, papers
used this illustration,
where you've already used
your third dimension, right?
You're not getting that back.
So I paid money, I paid good
money to licence that image
to put it in my book just
so I could use the caption,
"Making Cogs Great Again,"
so totally worth it.
[APPLAUSE]
And finally, two-pound coins--
when the two-pound coin came
out to celebrate the millennium,
there was a competition
to design it.
This was the winning entry.
And it's got different
concentric, I guess,
circles, bits, where it shows
different stages of UK history.
And the middle one, your
kind of mechanical age here,
is a series of cogs.
And because if a cog goes
clockwise, the one next to it
has to go anti-clockwise, then
clockwise, then anti-clockwise,
you have to have an even number
of cogs as you go around.
The two-pound coin has
an odd number of cogs.
It would not work.
People on the internet
were unimpressed and smug
in equal measure.
And the Royal Mint put
out a statement saying
that it doesn't matter, right?
It's just, what are
you going on about?
It's just meant to
represent that age.
And I was like, that's curious.
But I wonder, because
there's a 50-50--
I don't know what would
be a great example
to simulate a 50-50 chance.
Imagine flipping
something, right?
It could go either way.
If you do it at
random, you get an odd
or an even number of cogs.
And so I looked up the person
who designed this coin,
a guy called Bruce Russian.
He's an art teacher in Norfolk.
And on his website, he's
got his original design,
which would have worked.
It's an even number of cogs.
The actual coin that was
made, these three cogs
were removed, which meant
that it wouldn't work.
I was like, wow.
He had it right, and
the Royal Mint broke it.
But was that deliberate?
So I sent him an email.
I said, hey, I'm really sorry.
I'm sure people have
pointed this out
I'm just curious, because
I noticed you got it right.
Was that deliberate?
Did you think about it?
Was it a concern?
What happened?
I'm writing a book
about maths mistakes.
I'm curious to know, what
was your thought process?
And he replied to say that he
didn't think, as an artist,
it should have to be correct.
He thought it was
representative,
a bunch of cogs.
It doesn't make a difference
to the artistic worth
of the design.
And to be honest, I
kind of agree with him.
He then said that he decided
to make it work anyway,
because otherwise, he would
get loads of annoying emails
from pedants.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know why that was
in bold, but there you go.
And so yeah, so he
just thought, ah,
people are going to complain.
They're going to go
on and on about it.
And now, this is the
unfortunate edge,
because when I was writing
a book about maths mistakes,
I didn't want it to
be all about niche,
theoretical maths problems,
of which there are things--
people thought they had proved
something, and they hadn't.
And that's interesting
to a small demographic
that includes this guy.
But then there's also the kind
of pedantic, ah, you're wrong,
I'm right, which
is the opposite of,
it's fine to make
mistakes, which
is one of the things
I want to get across.
And a lot of mistakes
don't really matter.
So I hunted down a
copy of this book.
I remembered this from years
and years and years ago.
I didn't have as a child.
I must've seen some--
I mean, a lot of my
friends procreate.
And I saw somewhere this book.
This is a Sesame Street book.
This is Ernie expressing his
dislike of the possibility
of being forced to live on the
moon, which feels like a niche
concern, but there you go.
And I hunted down a
copy of this book.
I found it on the internet.
And there's one thing about
this which really bothers me.
It's not important.
It's not a major issue.
Does anyone, apart
from the child
who had a very loud
epiphany over there,
like to tell me
what's wrong with it?
There's stars where
the moon should be.
You are 100% correct.
What are these?
There's not a hole in the moon.
As far as I'm aware, in
the extended Sesame Street
universe, there are
not Muppet bases
that we can see twinkling
on the moon, right?
And so you often
see a crescent moon.
And then you see stars
shining through it.
And no, the moon is, well,
from our point of view, a disc,
right?
And it's always there.
It blocks out the stars.
We do see different bits,
depending on how it's lit.
And that's an artistic
version of that.
Bizarrely, I'm fine
with that, right?
But I'm like, ugh, they
shouldn't show stars
through the crescent
moon, right?
Come on, bit of
astronomy, everybody.
And then I was looking
around for other examples.
And actually, Sesame Street
have done this more than once.
And I was looking at,
separately, the licence plates
from the state of Texas.
So this is a plate from Texas.
And as you can see, it's
celebrating the fact
that the shuttle was
involved in Texas.
And there's the shuttle.
That's not a bad
angle, actually,
for the shuttle taking off.
That's surprisingly--
it hasn't got any
of its boosters or anything.
Maybe that's it landing.
I don't know.
I was distracted by
over here, that star.
That star is dangerously
close to that--
but the only way I
could know for sure
would be to somehow buy some
licence plates from Texas.
So I did that.
[LAUGHTER]
And they arrived in the post.
There we are.
This is actually genuinely--
I scanned it so I could get
a high-resolution version,
because all the ones
online were too low-res.
And if you zoom
right in, and you
fill in the rest of the moon--
[LAUGHTER]
Texas, undone by a lone star.
Oh, people have
since pointed out
that maybe it's marking where
the first Apollo landing
site was.
And it's very close.
I might give them that,
to be entirely honest.
But these problems--
they're not--
OK, if we're just
talking about, are there
practical implications
for the problems?
In this case, I mean,
don't get me wrong.
I'm a big fan of
getting maths correct,
and good maths PR, and
mass being important.
But just practically,
are they important?
And sadly, in those cases, not
really, not really important.
But sometimes, the
maths can be important.
So you may have noticed,
I am dancing around
a very large Jenga tower.
And I thought I would have
this set up during my show
to artificially increase
the amount of suspense
for narrative purposes.
No.
So this is to show a fantastic
effect about resonance.
So this is a building.
And we're going to
show you in a second
how a building resonates,
hopefully, to destruction.
We will see how lucky we get--
or unlucky, depending on what
I'm trying to do at the time.
Normally, you will hear
resonance discussed
when it comes to bridges.
And so there are
a lot of bridges
which have had resonance
problems, dating back into--
I think the earliest one I've
come across was in the 1800s,
up near Manchester,
where Salford is now.
There was a bridge.
And there were some troops
marching over the bridge.
Because they were
all in step, they
hit a resonance
frequency of the bridge.
And the bridge start to
move, which, apparently,
they thought was kind of fun.
So they started
singing a tune to match
the bouncing bridge, really
got involved, and it collapsed.
And no one died.
No one died.
It's OK.
It's difficult
writing-- because you
know when you cover engineering
and medical mistakes,
when I was putting
the book together,
I'm like, every second
story, everybody dies.
I can't have a comedy book
about maths, and every second--
every couple pages, and
then everybody died.
So I think, in all the
engineering examples
I'm going to give you,
nobody died, I think.
And all the aviation stories
in the book, nobody died.
Don't get me wrong, people do
die in aviation problems, just
not the ones I put in the book.
So that was the problem with
the bridge up near Manchester.
In London, you've still
got this one here.
This is the Albert Bridge.
All troops must break step
when marching over this bridge.
That sign is still there.
They must break step.
Interestingly, though,
they must not break dance--
very different rule.
[LAUGHTER]
And when I mention
this, a lot of
you are now thinking of
one of two famous bridges--
Tacoma Narrows Bridge--
this was a bridge
in the US, art deco bridge,
absolutely phenomenal,
incredible amount of twist.
Now, that's not your
standard resonance
from just people marching on
it, or even bursts of wind,
as you will occasionally
read online.
This is resonating.
But this is flutter.
This is aerodynamic flutter
from the wind coming up
the valley where it was.
And the flutter basically caused
this runaway feedback loop
where, as bridge came up,
more wind pushed it higher up.
When it finally bounced back and
down, more wind pushed it down.
And you got this feedback, which
led it to go more and more.
Someone finally decided maybe
they should leave their car.
Also, you've got the
Millennium Bridge in London.
This was opened
in the year 2000.
And it was only open
for a couple of days
before they had to close it.
They looked at the footage.
Now, if everyone's
walking randomly,
it should be fine,
because they're not all
going to match one
particular frequency.
But they looked at the footage.
About 20% of the pedestrians--
admittedly, it's quite crowded.
But 20% of them were
all marching in sync.
The bridge is moving about 7
and 1/2 centimetres either way,
which is about 7
and 1/2 too many.
And so they had to close it and
do all sorts of crazy things
to damp it, because
what was happening was,
the bridge was moving a bit.
And people were moving with it.
And so they were then stepping
in time with the bridge.
So the bridge moving was causing
the pedestrians to synchronise.
And the pedestrians
synchronising
was causing the bridge to move.
And you get this feedback loop.
The official wording was, it was
synchronous lateral excitation.
It was a feedback.
Energy was going in,
and it was matching
the resonant
frequency, which is,
of course, totally terrifying.
I'm more interested, though--
I've become obsessed with--
the bridges are one thing.
They're easy to move.
And we kind of-- for
the most part now,
we get-- which is
why the Millennium
Bridge was so amazing.
For the most part now
bridges, work fine.
Buildings, less so.
So there was a building
in South Korea in 2011,
which is disturbingly recently.
Anything within a decade,
I find terrifying.
It was a 39-story building.
And one day, in 2011, the
people on the 38th floor
evacuated because
they thought there
was an earthquake or something.
It was shaking like crazy.
They left the building.
No one else knew what
they were going on about.
The building was fine.
They were like, what?
They did an investigation.
And they recreated this,
so this is genuinely true.
It turns out, on the 12th
floor was an exercise class.
And about 20 people
decided to exercise
to a different song that day.
They exercised to Snap's
"I've Got the Power."
If you're unfamiliar with
Snap's "I've Got the Power"--
That would be better if
it was a dramatic, uh--
if you're unfamiliar with
Snap's "I've Got the Power"--
[MUSIC PLAYS BRIEFLY]
And that's as much as I can play
without the Royal Institution
getting a copyright
strike on their channel.
So they danced to that song.
The song happened to
match a resonant frequency
of the building.
And the 38th floor moved
10 times more than normal--
absolutely incredible.
So when people design
buildings, they
have to try and factor this in.
And it is a big problem, which
is what-- this is actually
kind of a teaching
aid for learning
about resonance in building.
And I've borrowed this
off a friend of mine
who is an engineer.
And they've actually
come along to give me
a hand, because I am not
qualified to run this,
and see what it can
show us about resonance.
So can you please
welcome to the stage,
from the University of
Bath, Paul Shepherd.
[APPLAUSE]
There he is.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank you.
I haven't seen you since
we put this back together.
OK, it's been minutes.
So don't pick that up.
Yeah, I get nervous.
OK, so first of all, what do you
do at the University of Bath?
I teach mathematics
to civil engineers.
I research how we
can use computers
to design better buildings.
And I've also got a role in
our Institute of Mathematical
Innovation, helping companies
with their maths problems.
Fantastic.
Notice how he started and ended
with maths to keep me happy.
So you use this in your
lectures, I believe.
Yes.
And just talk us through,
what is this bit of kit?
Literally, it's a
washing machine motor.
But let's not go there, right?
It really is.
This is a washing
machine motor in a box.
There's some magic in the box.
It causes the base to move
back and forth, vibrate.
And I have here a button that
you're not qualified to press--
That's the one.
--and a dial to make
it go faster or slower.
Is there like a safe slow?
Can we--
We can do it really--
Or do you want to leave it?
What do you want to do?
No, no, no, it's fine.
OK, here we go.
OK, so--
I can do it slow.
--we'll show it in action.
See if it still works.
I'll catch it if
it goes to fall.
Really slow, yeah?
Like, you know--
Oh, that is fantastically slow.
If anyone starts watching the
video right now, they're like,
it is playing at
the wrong speed.
Anyone still awake?
So that's it, right?
And on top of this, we've
built a Jenga tower.
Yeah.
And what we wanted
to demonstrate
with this is that if you hit the
resonant frequency of the Jenga
tower, it will fall over.
But to make it a
challenge, first we're
going to start with a frequency
where it won't fall over.
So we think we've found one.
We're unconvinced.
We put it back together
and went, oh, now it's
suddenly different.
And we'll have a slightly
different resonant frequency.
But let's give it a go.
Let's give it a go.
So shall we slam
straight into the--
Straight into the--
Oh, my goodness.
--right.
You're--
Yeah, yeah, I'm
going to catch it--
Can I move out of the way?
--just in case we get unlucky.
If you get unlucky,
it goes that way.
Oh, yeah.
If I get unlucky, it
goes-- right, here we go.
Here we go.
Here we go, yeah.
It's fine.
Look at it.
I would happily live
in that building.
[LAUGHTER]
So we've got it moving
at quite a frequency.
It's shaking--
don't get me wrong.
It's shaking it
all over the place.
But it's not falling over.
What we're going
to do now is, we're
going to keep the
amplitude the same,
because we can't adjust it.
And we're going to
reduce the frequency,
so we're shaking it less.
So do you want to
reduce the frequency?
Slowly, slow, yeah.
We'll slowly bring
the frequency down.
I'm going to move as well.
So now you can stand back.
There's now less shaking.
Sorry.
Wow, now I feel confident.
Less shaking.
And in theory, even though
we're shaking it less,
if we hit a resonant
frequency, it will fall over.
I think we're near one.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
[APPLAUSE]
Now, don't get me wrong.
As we're shaking
it slower, we're
putting less energy into it.
We were just putting the energy
in at just the right time
to build and accumulate in the
system rather than cancelling
out.
And so what-- so you showed
this to what, civil engineering
students?
Yes.
I mean, we don't want that
to happen to buildings.
And there's a certain
number of things
we can change to the
building to make sure
that the frequency at
which it would do that
is different from
the frequencies
that it would see
in its daily life.
OK.
So we--
And you can kind of tune
the building away from--
And you don't test it by
putting models on this.
No.
You run simulations
or something.
We do maths on it, obviously.
Ah, yes.
Correct answer, Paul.
And are there any
buildings-- can you
give us examples of buildings
you've done this on,
or you are under a lot of
nondisclosure agreements?
Not anymore.
Hey!
You're an academic now.
Well, I was working
on a bridge at--
I won't say which one--
at the same time as the wobbly
bridge across the Thames
had problems.
Oh, really?
So we were working--
I was working for, let's
say, a different company.
And of course, we watched that
and thought, well, we better
make trebly sure that's we're
not going to fall for this.
You're like, whoops.
Glad it happened to them first.
I mean, it did take the
world of engineering
a little bit by surprise that
it had happened so seriously.
So yeah, we can now
understand-- it was the person
element that we--
we knew the maths,
but we didn't quite understand
how people synchronised.
They're the unpredictable ones.
And now, in the two decades
since, when people design
bridges, do you--
or any building,
I guess-- do you have to
now factor in human movement
as well?
Yeah.
After that happened,
a lot of people
did a lot of
experiments and research
to work out how it happens
and to quantify it.
And now, that sort
of new research
is taken into account when
we design bridges today.
Oh, fantastic.
Excellent.
Can we have a huge round of
applause for Paul Shepherd?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
I mean, he's literally
just sat over there now.
But his mike has
been turned off.
OK, right so I
think this is great,
because the thing
about engineering
is, we're often building
things beyond our current full
mathematical understanding.
We use maths to build things
which no longer make sense
intuitively, because if
you look at something like
the Millennium Bridge,
you can't just go,
that will wobble or that won't.
Or indeed, most of the
perfectly stable buildings,
before we had computers
and advanced maths,
we built them out of
massive bits of rocks,
where you can look
at it and go, yep,
that's not going anywhere,
whereas now, we need computers
and mathematics to check.
And occasionally,
things go wrong.
We will forget about a factor.
Or there's a new bit of
mathematical behaviour will
emerge.
And then the engineering
industry learns, improves,
and the maths is
developed, and we
carry on building more and
more ridiculous things.
OK, so I'm going to leave
these here and continue
to carefully dance around them.
What I thought I
would do, because I've
got one more guest at the
end who's brought something
else along to show you.
But between now and then,
I had so many stories,
because this-- like, I just
had hundreds and hundreds
of stories, of which a couple
hundred made it into the book.
And I couldn't decide
which ones I was
going to show you here today.
So what I thought I would
do is pick them at random.
So I have here a spinning wheel.
And so what we can do
is, if we spin the wheel,
it will settle on
one of the colours.
This is not it.
We'll do it again in a second.
So we get a colour.
And up here, I've got a
breakdown of what the colours
mean.
So we would do a story
about programming, right?
Boom, programming story.
I get a programming
story on the laptop.
We do it.
We have a great time.
We do this a few times.
Then we bring on the final
guest-- very straightforward.
So I'm going to get
some volunteers to come
down and-- no, not yet.
You haven't heard all the rules.
I think I'm going to
do this three times.
That's my guess, three times.
And so my plan is, if we have
three different volunteers,
we will start with a
very young volunteer.
We will then have more of a
teenage, high school volunteer.
And then we'll have
an adult volunteer.
So if people watch this
quickly, or they just--
or it's edited down, it will
look like the one volunteer
ageing rapidly--
[LAUGHTER]
--throughout the talk.
OK, so are there any--
wait for the end
of the sentence--
any young volunteers would
like to come down and be first?
Over there, over at the back.
Give me a wave.
You get round of applause.
Come on down.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
It's very nice to meet you.
What's your name?
Maria.
Maria, nice to meet you.
Would you like to
come over here, Maria?
So you can see I've
got my spinner here.
What I want you to do
is to grab one of these
and just give it a real spin.
And we'll see which of any
of the colours it ends up on.
Off you go.
Good spin.
Whatever colour it is, just
say the category nice and loud.
Ooh, it's just in green.
What's green?
Probability.
Thank you very much.
Give her a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Give me a second to find
my probability slides.
There we go.
OK, so we're going to start
with a tale about probability
and how humans are
bad at probability.
And this is one of my
favourite examples,
where we can try to
scam someone, right?
We can try and trick someone
into thinking it's a fair game,
when actually, it's not.
So for this, I need a volunteer.
However, I'm going to take one
from someone right at the top.
Is there anyone--
because you don't
have to come down for this.
You remain completely in situ.
Let's go with the person over
there, leaning on the rail,
at the back.
Yep, give me a wave.
Excellent.
What's your name, very loud?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, we can't hear you.
OK, so--
[LAUGHTER]
So what we're going to do--
we're going to flip
a coin down here.
It's going to be
heads or tails, right?
And you're going to try and
predict if it's heads or tails.
Has anyone down here got
a coin, any of the adults
got a coin they're
prepared to flip for me?
Sir, are you happy to
be our coin flipper?
OK, you can stay there.
You flip the coin--
very straightforward.
OK, right.
So what we're going to do is,
we're going to flip the coin.
You're going to predict it.
Would you like heads or tails?
[INAUDIBLE]
You feel like this is going
to be a double-sided coin.
I feel like we're having more of
a conversation than I expected.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's have a--
give you the coin.
Oh, my goodness.
OK, ready?
No, I'm not throwing it.
Who would you like
to verify the coin?
Pick a human.
The one next to you.
Pick a human who's
closer to me than you.
It's OK.
I've got a solution.
Don't worry.
Would anyone like to know--
OK, OK.
Who-- there?
There.
That one.
OK.
Can you have a look at that?
Is it a head on both sides?
No.
Is it tails on one side?
Yeah.
Excellent.
Wow.
That was anticlimactic.
Here you are.
You are now deemed trustworthy.
By simply saying either the
word "heads" or the word
"tails," what do you
think it's going to be?
Tails.
Tails, OK.
Everyone, in your
own minds, decide
what you think it's going
to be, heads or tails,
in your own minds.
OK, flip it, and then
call it out nice and loud,
so we can all hear it.
Good flip, solid flip.
What is it?
Tails.
Who's right?
Hands up if you're right.
OK, half of you.
Hands up if you're wrong.
OK, OK, slightly more, because,
you know, adorable kid.
OK.
So was that fair, though?
And by the way, it's
not a trick coin.
There's nothing fancy going on.
It's not because there's
more metal on one
side than the other, right?
Assuming that is a
perfectly fair coin,
everyone should be happy.
That was a perfectly
fair challenge.
In fact, if we were to bet
money, which, young people,
you shouldn't, right?
But were you to do
such a thing, you
would have a 50-50 chance
of winning versus losing.
And if you played it
over and over again,
you would win as
often as you lose.
If you played the
same person, you
would end up passing money back
pretty much at random, right?
No one has an
advantage in that game.
We could make the game
slightly more exciting
by having more than one flip.
So if, instead of asking
you what one flip would be,
I could say, we're
going to flip it--
we'll do two flips.
So you can choose
heads-heads, or heads-tails,
or tails-heads, or tails-tails.
What would you like, actually?
What would you like?
Tails-tails.
Tails-tails, all right.
And everyone here could
think of their own one
that they want to have.
And if we flipped it,
you've all got a 1
in 4 chance of being right.
Or if we're playing two of us,
if we don't get it straight
away, we could keep
flipping it until one of us
has our run come up first.
Still a fair coin,
must be still fair.
What if we did three?
In fact, everyone,
in your own minds,
decide what three flips in
a row-- heads-tails-heads,
heads-tails-tails,
heads-tails-tails--
in your own minds, decide what
you think it's going to be.
What did you decide up there?
Tails-tails.
You get one more.
Heads.
Tails-tails-heads, right?
In fact, here they all are.
There's all the options.
So you may have
picked one of those.
And they're all equally likely.
I'm now going to bet all of
you simultaneously that mine
will come up before yours.
So I want you to
have a look at this.
And I want you to choose
which one is yours.
Make sure you choose
And then I'm going to add my
predictions next to yours.
So if you predicted
heads-heads-tails,
I predict tails-heads-heads,
because I'm
playing you all individually.
If you pick tails-tails-heads,
I've picked heads-tails-tails.
I have different predictions.
I mean, some of
them are the same.
But I mix up the predictions
based on what you said.
So everyone, make sure you're
happy-- which one is yours,
and my prediction next to it.
Have you all got that?
OK.
So what we're going
to do now is we're
going to start flipping the coin
until either you win or I win.
And we'll keep going until
every single game is finished.
So first one up, flip the coin.
What have you got?
Heads.
Second one.
Ooh.
Third one.
Tails.
So a lot of people are now
happy they've just won.
If you said heads-heads-tails,
you have just beaten me.
I said tails-heads-heads,
which has not come up.
But some people,
yours isn't here yet.
So, Todd, can you flip it again?
Great, I love it.
You're being more
enthusiastic each time.
Tails.
So now, can you see?
The last three are
now heads-tails-tails.
So if you had heads-tails-tails,
you have now won.
If I had heads-tails-tails,
I've now won.
Or if I had heads-heads-tails
against yours, I've now won.
You need to keep track
who wins first, you or me.
So if either I beat you
with heads-heads-tails
or I've beaten you
with heads-tails-tails,
just bear that in mind.
OK, give us another flip.
Heads.
So the next one up
his tails-tails-heads,
tails-tails-heads.
Up next?
Tails.
Tails-heads-tails,
tails-heads-tails,
tails-heads-tails.
OK.
Tails.
Heads-tails-tails,
heads-tails-tails.
Is anyone still in the game?
What are you thinking of?
Which ones are yours?
Heads-heads-heads.
And what did I
predict against that?
Tails-heads-heads.
That hasn't come up.
Oh my goodness.
OK, let's keep going, eh?
Next one.
Who's going to win?
Heads.
Tails-tails-heads.
Tails.
Tails-heads-tails.
They're still both
in the competition.
Someone else has either
won or gone out, right?
Yep.
Heads.
Heads-tails-heads.
That's the beginning
of your run.
Here we go.
Heads.
Oh, but you were about to win.
Aw.
Is anyone still in the game?
What were you on?
Heads-tails-heads.
Heads-tails-heads, I
predicted heads-heads-tails,
which was the first one out.
So it's fine.
Don't worry.
We'll edit this
out of the video.
(WHISPERING) We're not going
to edit it out of the video.
[LAUGHTER]
So very quickly,
before, when it was
heads or tails, roughly
half the audience,
roughly, got it correct.
Put your hand up if I
won the game against you.
That's the vast majority of you.
And hands up if you won.
Oh, a few people.
OK, what did you--
the people who picked
me, what did you go for?
Heads-heads-tails.
Heads-heads-tails, which was
straight out of the gate,
right?
So 1 in 8 of you will win
straight out of the gate.
If you play this
game over and over,
and the person you're playing
against picks randomly,
I will win 74% of the time.
Roughly 3/4 of a time,
the one I've put in white
will beat the one in
orange next to it.
And the reason this works,
and the reason it's not fair,
is we don't flip the coin three
times and then start again.
If we did it three times,
start again, three times,
start again, it would
be perfectly fair.
Because they're overlapping,
they're no longer
independent probabilities.
They're now dependent
probabilities.
And if you look at
mine, all of mine will--
mine all end in what your
prediction starts with.
I'm trying to make
mine happen right
before yours, which is why
I got yours, because I knew,
if you've got heads-heads-heads,
unless the first three
flips are heads-heads-heads,
I'm going to win,
because tails-heads-heads
will always come first.
So let's say we've been
flipping the coin for ages.
And someone picked all
tails, the opposite of you,
and someone picked--
I picked heads-tails-tails.
If the coins being flip,
flip, flip, flip, flip,
and you're like, ah,
here we go at last,
it's going to be
tails-tails-tails,
as soon as you get the first two
in the run, I've already won.
Unless the first three
flips are tails-tails-tails
or heads-heads-heads,
you cannot win.
So there's a 1 and 8
chance you will win.
And there's a 7 in
8 chance I will win.
And the other ones are
different variations
on that theme with
different probabilities.
And if you average them
all, you get the 74% figure.
And people don't really
think through when
you get these unusual
probabilities combining.
I actually-- I carry with
me a set of dice, which
I thought I'd get out if we
have probability on the spinner
wheel.
These are called Grime Dice.
And they have unusual
numbers on them.
And I appreciate you
can't really see them.
So I've got-- I'll show
it up on the screen here.
So the yellow one, you
can see there, has got--
it's got an eight.
It's got some threes.
The green has got a zero.
What's going on there?
They've got crazy
numbers on them.
They're not one to six.
And the game you play
is, choose a dice.
So you pick one colour.
I pick a different colour.
We roll them together.
Highest number wins.
Very straightforward, right?
Except they're not all
equally likely to win,
because they've got
different numbers.
But it's very hard to tell at a
glance which is the best dice.
I can now reveal
to you that if you
roll the red one
versus the blue one,
the red one will win more
often than the blue--
not all the time,
but more often.
It's above 50%.
The blue one wins more
often than the green.
The green wins more
often than the yellow.
Yellow wins more
often than magenta.
And so you get this
fantastic ordering
from the best dice, which is
the red, down to the worst dice,
which is the magenta,
or so you would think.
If you play magenta
versus red, the magenta
wins more often
than the red one.
There's no best dice.
If you remember this cycle, and
the person you're playing picks
first, you can
always pick a dice
which has a higher probability
of winning than they do, same
as the dice game, penny ante.
As long as the other
person picks first,
you can always pick one that's
better, which feels weird.
But it's the same as
rock paper scissors.
It's like playing
rock paper scissors,
but going, you go first,
and then I'll choose.
There's no best option.
But each one's better
than another one.
And each one loses to
another one-- same deal
on a higher scale.
If you do play this, though,
it gets a bit terrifying,
because if people realise
you're beating them,
they will make you
tell them the secret.
And then you say,
oh, I can't do it.
I'll teach you the secret.
And now we'll play
two dice together.
Why not?
What they won't realise
is, if you play two dice
simultaneously, it
reverses the order.
So they will now--
you will pick first.
And they will then
deliberately pick the one that
loses, because you've got two.
So that's the single dice game.
That's the double dice game.
If you're wondering what
on earth is going on here,
I've got a quick equation.
There you go.
Huh?
[LAUGHTER]
It's also got more
than one cycle,
because there's another
internal cycle of five
in a different order.
And if you double the dice, the
internal cycle doesn't reverse.
All it does is, the
top one becomes even.
So there's the double dice.
There's the single dice.
And so the outside
one's flipping,
but the inside one isn't.
If you're wondering
what's going on there,
there's the new equation.
[LAUGHTER]
And I absolutely love them.
If you want some details,
they-- the colours--
I'm came up with the colours.
Friend of mine, guy called
James Grime, did the numbers.
I did the colours.
I'm helping, because I said,
if they're these colours,
then the length of the colour
goes up by one letter as you go
around the outside cycle,
which is why that's magenta,
not purple.
Purple has insufficient letters.
And then James was like,
well, if we make this one
olive instead of
green, the inner cycle
is now alphabetical order.
So you can now remember
both cycles by looking
at the colours.
If you want all the stats,
here are your advantages
for any given pairing.
The inner cycle is
actually slightly stronger.
The other one-- here's
all your numbers.
Every single one is
above 50%, apart from--
we couldn't quite get
this one up to 50.
It's just below,
because sadly, there's
nothing magical
about these dice.
There's no incredible
maths property.
It's just that when you
put numbers on dice,
it's very hard to tell if they
form a non-transitive cycle
or a transitive cycle.
And non-transitive just means--
like, numbers are
transitive, because if 3--
let's say 7 is bigger than
3, and 3 is bigger than 1,
then 7 is bigger than 1.
It's a transitive property
that passes down the chain.
Just because red beats
blue and blue beats green
doesn't mean red
beats green, right?
It's not a property that
gets passed down the chain.
And it's things like
this which throw humans,
when we think we
understand probability,
but then it's just
a little bit off.
So I think we've got time
for another quick spin
of the wheel.
I need a teenager this time.
Anyone prepared to come
down and give me a hand?
You look very keen
right in the centre.
Would you like to come
down and spin the wheel?
You get the applause once you
get to the aisle, not before.
[CLAP]
No.
[LAUGHTER]
It gets awkward.
Otherwise, we're just applauding
other people awkwardly moving.
It's not good.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
What was your name?
Sasha.
Very nice to meet you, Sasha.
So you saw how this goes.
You grab it.
You give it a spin.
Whatever colour it ends up on,
you say very loudly what it
was.
OK, off you go.
OK, and we're going
to be talking about--
OK, probability.
Excellent.
Round of applause for Sasha.
[APPLAUSE]
Wow.
What are the chances?
So probability-- I think
I've got a second probability
thing here.
Give me a second.
Give me a-- oh, yeah, no,
OK, this is kind of fun.
This is an old classic.
So way back in the
distant past, 2010,
I saw a newspaper story about
someone who had analysed
the locations of the ancient
monolithic sites in the UK.
And they realised that
they formed patterns.
Specifically, if you took the
1,500 main monolithic ancient
sites-- these are
prehistoric sites--
and you analysed
their positions,
they formed triangles.
More than that, they formed
very precise triangles,
isosceles triangles where
two sides are exactly
the same length.
And they were within like half
a percent, incredible precision.
And the person who found
this put out a press release.
It was in all the papers.
They claimed it was some
kind of ancient sat nav
and that they used these
geometric arrangements
of monolithic sites to navigate
across the United Kingdom.
And the researchers said that
the results were so precise,
they could not have
happened by accident.
In fact, they couldn't rule
out extraterrestrial help.
So I thought I would check.
So I went and also
got some ancient sites
and started plotting them on
a map of the United Kingdom.
And the first three I came
across around Birmingham
formed a perfect
equilateral triangle
within the required
half a percent.
And then, I forgot, I
added in more triangles.
You've also got two isosceles
triangles on either side,
both within the half a
percent, another pair
of isosceles triangles,
both within the required
half a percent.
The base and the
perpendicular bisector
go through four new locations.
The location in Conaway is
within 12 metres of this line.
It then goes over 170 miles
across the United Kingdom,
right through the
base of the triangle,
hits Luton, where it's within
nine metres of that spot--
incredibly precise patterns.
I was like, wow, this can't
have happened by accident,
except I wasn't analysing
ancient monolithic sites.
I had looked up the ancient
Woolworth's stores--
[LAUGHTER]
--who had gone bankrupt
slightly before.
And we had already forgotten
how the people of 2008 lived.
I mean, how did they buy
discount plastic goods
and clothing?
We just don't know.
And for the young
people who aren't
familiar with Woolworth's,
they had a business model
where they were like, let's
just get all the confectionery
and put it in open containers,
let people help themselves,
and assume nothing will go
wrong with that business model.
So they went out of business.
I found the 800 Woolworth's
locations around the UK.
And I analysed them.
And I found the same patterns
to the same level of precision
as the other person
who had found
who was claiming
either ancient wisdom,
or aliens, or all
these things, right?
So I put out my findings
as a press release
about how we could learn
about the ancient Woolworth's
civilisation.
The Guardian went with
"Aliens Found Woolworth's
Civilization," which
was pretty funny.
It turns out, there
are just lots and lots
of stores to choose from.
So specifically,
here are the ones
I had with their postcodes.
They're all legitimate stores.
You can fact check this.
But here are all
the stores, right?
If you've got-- I
checked the numbers.
If you have 800
Woolworth's stores,
there are 85 million
possible triangles.
If you have 85
million triangles,
it would be more amazing if none
of them were isosceles, right?
There are so many options.
If you look hard enough,
you will definitely
find this pattern
or any pattern.
Mathematically,
we can state, you
can find any pattern you want
to any level of precision
you want if you're prepared
to ignore enough data.
The 1,500 stores the
other person had used
gave them 561 million triangles.
Of course, in 561
million triangles,
there are going to be a
few that line up, right?
We're just ignoring
loads of data and cherry
picking the little
bits which confirm
whatever our bias may be.
And every so often, this person
would put out more findings.
And I would put out other
ridiculous press releases,
up to and including a
programme-- a friend of mine,
a guy called Tom Scott,
programmed a website based
on the Woolworth's thing,
except he used monolithic sites
and postcodes.
So he found, for every single
postcode in the United Kingdom,
there are three ley lines that
go through it by joining up
other monolithic sites.
And one of them
will be Stonehenge--
every single postcode.
I can guarantee you can now
tell everyone your house,
your postcode, is definitely at
the centre of three ley lines,
one of which go
through Stonehenge,
because it's true of everywhere
on the United Kingdom.
Just a lot of old things
are lying around, right?
And I get so annoyed
when people go,
this data confirms
whatever my theory is.
And they're not asking how
much data didn't confirm it.
You always want
to know, if you're
doing good, proper science,
how much you're ignoring,
what your method was, how you
can falsify what you believe,
and then honestly and rigorously
checking that, and then getting
other people to check it.
Don't leave it to people
like me to make fun of you
in the newspaper.
OK, I think we
got time for one--
let's do one quick
last spin of the wheel.
And then I'll bring
on our final guest.
So for this one, I need an adult
who's prepared to come down.
Is there anyone
who's prepared to--
I mean, you're
practically here already.
Give them around of applause.
Here they come!
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Matt.
What was your name?
Matthew.
That's easy to remember.
OK, so Matthew, we're
going to spin the wheel.
Whatever it lands on, we're
going to talk about it.
Off you go.
Oh, is that just in probability?
Yes!
A round of applause for Matthew!
[APPLAUSE]
No, it does land
on other colours.
Oh well.
OK, so I'm very quickly going
to talk about-- wow, three--
I didn't have a
third probability?
Oh, I have got one here.
Let me get that.
I'm going to show
you my all-time--
stay with me, everyone-- my
all-time favourite photo.
This is my absolute
favourite photo.
And this was taken in 1980.
That is Donna.
She was on a holiday--
oh, a vacation--
she's North American--
going to one of the
Disney World or Lands.
And when she was there, she got
this photo taken with a Smee.
This is Smee, right?
And the probability-- the
amazing thing about this is not
that someone actually wanted
a photograph with Smee,
but what was happening
in the background,
because many years later, she
met her fianc, Alex, right?
They obviously got engaged.
And one day, she
was showing Alex
the photographs
from her childhood,
showed him this photograph.
And he went, oh, that's odd.
That looks like my dad.
Wait, that's me.
She was accidentally
photographed
with the person she
would later go on
to marry decades before
they actually met, right?
And that's amazing.
Like, the media
lost their minds.
Like, imagine imagine
being in a photo as a kid,
and someone just wheels
your future spouse
into the background.
It's incredible.
But I was like,
no, it's not fate.
It's not romance.
It's statistics, because
how likely is the--
OK, this is unlikely to
happen to any one given human,
because over the
course of your life,
particularly now there are
cameras absolutely everywhere,
you'll be photographed
with, I don't know,
1,000 or so random people
in backgrounds of photos.
Who knows, right?
Let's say about 1,000.
And it's reasonably
unlikely that you will go on
to have a significant
relationship with any
of those random people.
There's possibly
billions of people
that you could go on to have
relationships with, right?
And so 1,000 out of billions--
I mean, obviously, it
depends how big a-- you know,
how much mixing in the
populations you're in.
There are other factors.
But it's very
unlikely, except it
can happen to a lot of people.
It couldn't just happen to you.
It could happen to everyone.
It could happen to those
billions of people.
I would argue the
population size cancels out.
There should be
thousands of photographs
like this out there, right?
This is not amazing.
We expect it to happen.
We just don't expect it to
happen to anyone specific.
We wouldn't know who
Donna and Alex are.
They're just some
random North Americans.
We would have no idea, right?
It's only because the
photograph happened.
It's a bit like
winning the lottery.
It's amazing if you
win the lottery.
That's incredible.
It's not amazing if
someone wins the lottery.
You don't see the
newspaper, oh my goodness!
Someone won the lottery again.
Just keeps happening.
Well, yes.
Millions of people play
the lottery, right?
People forget about how many
opportunities these things
have.
And I went on tour a
couple of years ago
and did a show called
"Number Ninja."
And when I was on tour,
I showed this photograph
and talked about how
likely I thought it was.
And sure enough, in one
show, somebody came up to me
and said, oh, this happened
to some friends of mine.
A friend of mine, Kate, she
met someone called Chris
in Sheffield in 1993.
And they got engaged.
And they went on a world tour
to celebrate their engagement.
And as they were travelling
around the planet,
they went to visit some
distant, distant relatives
of Kate's in Outback,
Western Australia,
which really is the middle
of nowhere, all right?
I've been there, right?
And they were visiting
one particular family
on one particular farm.
And the wife in
that family said,
oh, it's so great you're here.
My husband and I, we went to the
UK once years ago, once, right?
And we took a whole
bunch of photos.
And we got one photo,
one specific photo,
that we don't know
where we took it.
All the other
ones, we've written
the location on the back.
This one, we have no idea.
And they were like, oh, OK.
Well, let's have a look, right?
And so they went in.
They got the photo.
They pulled it out.
And Chris looked at it and
went, oh, that looks like--
oh, that's Trafalgar
Square, right?
You're feeding the pigeons
in Trafalgar Square.
Wait a minute.
That's me!
[LAUGHTER]
Imagine travelling halfway
around the world to be reminded
of how much denim
you wore as a kid.
I mean, that's-- wow.
And it was like the one time
as a kid his family went down
to London, happened
to be photographed
by a distant relative of the
person he would go on to marry.
And then it was
the one photograph
that they wanted
to show you when
you happened to
visit in this other--
it's just insane, right?
And again, they showed
this at their wedding,
about how incredible it was
that they had this photo.
And that's true.
It is incredible for them.
It's just not incredible
that it happens.
Always, you just got to remember
how many opportunities things
have to happen.
In fact, you can
kind of exploit that.
So I've got a-- this is an
old-school one-pound coin,
the old circular ones,
before they got rid of them.
I'm going to flip it so it
lands on its edge, right?
So flip the coin,
land, edge, OK?
OK, here we go.
Ready?
That's dangerously close.
Oh!
That's so close.
Wouldn't that have been amazing?
I mean, I thought I was just
going to have to stand here,
doing the same thing over
and over again, but no.
No, actually, that was--
the pound coin, I think,
is the most likely thing
to land on its edge.
And just so you know,
that doesn't always
happen, by the way.
There's not an edge.
I happened to get lucky
on the first flip, right?
It genuinely does happen.
I could actually-- I could sit
here for-- ooh, that was close.
I could sit here and flip
it thousands of times.
Eventually, it would land
on its edge, which I know,
because I did.
So this was me flipping a coin
until it lands on its edge.
I wanted to see how
many edges I could get.
And some of them, I wasn't sure
if they should count or not.
So I want your
opinion on this one.
OK, here we go.
This is me flipping a coin
so it lands on its edge.
Flip the coin.
Look at that!
Wait, wait.
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Aw.
Does that count?
Vote if you think that counts.
Vote if you think it doesn't.
You're right.
It does not.
I kept going.
I flipped this specific
coin 10,000 times.
Oh, I haven't put
the video out yet.
So people watching
this, spoiler.
Don't tell anyone else.
That video will be out soon.
I flipped it-- because I did,
like, funny videos like, here's
how you flip a coin till
it lands on its edge.
Boom, thanks, right?
There's a video.
And I kept going, going, going.
14-- 14 edges out
of 10,000 flips.
I believe the old circular
pound coin is the most likely to
land on its edge
of all the coins.
That's my theory.
And it seems pretty likely.
I couldn't believe I
almost got an edge just--
aw.
Right?
And so if you ever want
to pass, in my experience,
three days of your
life, get involved.
OK, so I think we've done enough
ridiculous bits of probability.
We'll go back to the show
as I originally planned.
Oh, and to be honest,
I am quite glad.
It's great example
of probability.
If you do something
often enough,
weird things will happen.
I like the fact that we got
three probabilities in a row.
I think that's
actually quite a good--
quite a good message,
although the bizarre thing
is, this is the first
time I have ever done
this talk, right?
And it happened straight away.
And for those of you
watching the video,
it's because we
sat here and kept
spinning it until we got
probability every single time.
This is the most
patient audience
I've had for some time.
And this is a lesson
in not believing
things you see on the internet.
So good moral.
[APPLAUSE]
Man, the second
one took forever.
OK, yeah, that's not the
actual moral of the story.
OK, I'm going to bring
up my final guest
and show you one more thing.
And then I'll wrap up.
And as was mentioned
the beginning,
there are books
available on the way out.
I'm also doing a show at the
Edinburgh Fringe coming up.
And I'm doing a book
tour afterwards,
which is completely
different to this.
So if you watch this, or
you watch this online,
I'm doing shows afterwards
about Humble Pi.
But I've deliberately made
this a special show just
for the Royal Institution,
because I'm not
doing that again.
And so if you see
me on tour, it'll
be a totally different show.
And it'll be great to
see some of the shows.
Right, so the very last
thing I'm going to show you
is a problem, once
again, with engineering.
So we did structural,
like civil engineering.
We're now going
to look at, well,
engineering that
brought down a rocket.
There was a rocket,
the Ariane 5 rocket,
which was being launched by ESA.
And 40 seconds after it
took off, it exploded.
Thankfully, it was
unstaffed, right?
There were no humans onboard.
It was just payload
of other spacecraft.
But of course, someone had
built those spacecraft.
And they were obviously
very attached to them.
And a simple mathematical error
caused the rocket to explode.
And the spacecraft rained
down on the swamp underneath.
And I will explain what the
maths mistake was in a second.
But the bits of
spacecraft, they then
sent them back to the
people who had made them
and were waiting to
send them into space.
And to show us the mangled bits
of spacecraft from the Mullard
Space Science Laboratory at
UCL, please welcome Lucy Green.
[APPLAUSE]
Do you want to go get them?
Yeah.
I'll get them.
I say welcome.
She's going to arrive, and then
go away again, and then come
back.
So I asked Lucy very kindly
if she could go and find
the bits of spacecraft.
Do you want to--
very carefully-- we'll
wheel it out the front here.
So these are-- so what
spacecraft was this?
So these are bits of
instruments that we
flew on the Cluster spacecraft.
So there's four of them,
actually, so four of them--
All on the same rocket?
All on the same rocket, yeah.
That was a big mistake.
And they posted them
back to the lab?
Yes.
So when the rocket obviously
came down, as you said,
not that long after launch,
it fell into the swamp
in French Guiana.
And so the European
Space Agency had
people who could go out
and rescue the rocket
and get the pieces back.
So we then got our
instruments sent back.
And apparently, I wasn't
there at the time,
but the story goes
that we got the box.
And they opened it up.
And there was still
bits of swamp in it
and bits of our instrument, too.
So this is one of
the brains of one
of the instruments on Cluster.
So we built the instrument
that measures-- well, we
can talk about what
the mission did.
But it was sent up to
study the environment
around the Earth, so the
magnetic field of the Earth
and the particle environment.
And this is the brains
of the instrument
that measured the electrons
in the environment
around the Earth.
And what research do you do?
You're on--
So my research is
really related.
I study the Sun.
And I'm interested in how
the Sun's activity impacts
the Earth's magnetic
field, creating
something called space weather.
And this Cluster
mission was designed
to study space weather.
So one of the
things that did was
look at the physical processes
behind the generation
of the aurora, the
northern lights.
And the aurora are
generated by solar activity.
That sounds useful.
I mean, I say what do
you do like I don't know.
I'm actually married to
Lucy, just so we're--
because otherwise, that was--
I thought it was
quite convincing.
If your parents are watching,
they're like, he never asked.
So we've got meteorite rings.
Look at us.
Ah, nerds.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
I assume you're wearing it.
I'm wearing it.
You're wearing the gloves,
by the way, because--
why do you have to wear
gloves handling this?
Well, because we
think it's probably
still covered in rocket fuel.
So--
And that's not good for you.
It's not good for you.
And I don't want
to get on my hands
and then go and eat
my dinner later.
But I mean, it's pretty
cool to see these bits that
are completely mangled up.
And normally, our
instruments don't come back.
So these bits were built
in our laboratories.
And now we've got
them back again.
I think, on one
of them, there was
a little tag that said
UCL's Mullard Space Science
Laboratory.
So someone was like, you
know, if found, please send it
home to us.
They figured that would
take millions of years
and be some distant
civilization.
But no, it was within our--
Yeah, so you can see.
And so when you arrived--
you started working there
just after this had happened.
Just after this had happened.
So when we launched the
spacecraft, of course,
we want to have a big party.
Everyone gets
together to celebrate.
And they'd bought champagne
to drink after the launch.
And I arrived about
two years later.
And that champagne was still
there, sadly, undrunk, yeah.
But I mean, we could talk
about the success story,
because we did go on to
rebuild these instruments.
So they were launched again.
They were launched again, yes.
So the European Space
Agency gave us the money
to rebuild the instruments.
And it took much less time.
So within four years, they had
been rebuilt and relaunched.
And they're still running.
So we launched in 2000.
And what are we now?
2019.
The ones that are in
space now are still
operating successfully.
Wow, because this
blew up in '96.
'96.
So they really did turn
around quite quick.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
And so we actually-- we were
chatting to a friend of yours.
And we didn't realise.
This was literally last night.
We were chatting to a friend.
And she was like, oh, I was
watching the live stream,
because my PhD was
going to be on Cluster.
And so she was a
first-year PhD student
watching the live stream.
And we were like, what happened?
And she was like,
the room was silent.
And then everybody left.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow.
And she was like, well,
different PhD, I guess.
And so where do these live now?
So these live in my department.
We have some on display,
because as I said,
we built four instruments.
So we've got quite a lot
of this mangled hardware.
And we, yeah, we keep them out.
We talk to people about the
mission, talk about what we did
successfully to launch again.
And I think it just
serves as a reminder
that it doesn't always work.
No.
OK, so we'll wheel these off
before I actually touch them.
They're broken already.
They're broken.
That's OK.
Round of applause for
Professor Lucy Green.
[APPLAUSE]
It's all right.
People spend so long
working on a spacecraft.
Like, a mission is
decades to get it to work.
And they have some of them out
in the coffee room at the lab,
just like in the glass
case, so a reminder
for the next generation
of space scientists
that your decades of
work may disappear
in a fraction of a second
and land in a swamp.
And what happened
with that was, there
was one sensor in the navigation
part of the Ariane 5 rocket
which-- well, so this
part of the rocket
took input from several sensors.
It took the raw data coming
in from those sensors,
converted it into meaningful
navigation information,
and then sent that to
the main processor that
was kind of driving the
rocket, if you will.
And when the numbers
were coming in,
they had to work out how
big they were going to be,
because you have to allocate
a certain amount of memory.
And they tended to allocate
just 16 bits, 16 ones and zeros,
for a value coming in.
But some of them
might be bigger.
They could be up to 64.
And so what they did, because
they could have just written
something in the
programme which was,
for every input that comes in,
check how big it is before you
try and send it into the memory.
But that's quite
processor intensive.
And they had quite strict
limitations on how much power
they were allowed to use.
And so instead of checking
every single sensor,
they looked for all
the sensors which
could give a number bigger
than 16 binary digits.
And they would check those
to avoid any problems.
And the ones that never
could be that big,
they didn't bother checking.
And they could save
some processing.
And that all worked really,
really well on the Ariane 4.
They then copied
it to the Ariane 5
without double checking.
And because of a different
take-off trajectory
and because of the way
the sensors worked,
one of the sensors
that previously
wasn't being checked, well,
continued to not be checked,
but now should
have been checked.
And it actually
didn't have to be on.
They just left it
on after launch.
It was a prelaunch sensor,
because if there was ever a go
to launch, and then they
aborted before takeoff,
and then they reset, it
took forever to reset.
So they didn't turn
them off straight away.
They let them run for a while
and then turned them off
once they were sure it
was definitely safe.
However, it continued
to run as it took off.
It got a value that was too big.
It didn't fit in the
memory it put it in.
It rolled over to the
memory next to it.
And the whole thing crashed,
which, in and of itself,
wouldn't have been the worst
thing, because it could have
restarted or something,
except it was designed
to give a crash report.
So like the stereotypical,
someone's like, ah,
tell my spouse I love
them, but this is like,
ah, tell my debugger the
following crash context
information.
And so it sent the debug
message up the same link
to the main processor, which
didn't know that could happen.
It thought it was
navigation data,
thought the rocket had
suddenly gone off to one side,
tried to correct, except it
hadn't gone off to one side.
And the correction threw
it off to one side.
It tore it apart.
The self-destruct
sequence kicked in.
And because a
64-digit number was
tried to put in
a 16-digit space,
this whole rocket exploded.
And possibly-- because the
spacecraft weren't insured,
which is amazing--
however, ESA did decide
to refund it, right?
So one slight maths error can
have phenomenal implications.
And that is pretty
much it from me.
I guess, in conclusion, I
started with the theory of,
are mistakes important?
And in some cases, yes.
We have to get the maths right.
I mean, we'll get it
wrong occasionally.
But we have to get
it right in a lot
of these critical situations.
And that means we need
people who are good at maths
and are prepared to put the
effort in, because with maths,
we can do more than our brains
were originally built to do,
right?
We can go beyond our intuition,
which I think is incredible.
But ironically, to get
mathematicians and people who
are prepared to put the effort
in, and work hard, and more
importantly, come
up with systems
that accept that humans
will make mistakes,
and we can use our
same mathematical logic
to have robust
systems where mistakes
don't become disasters--
to have all of
that, we need people
who weren't afraid to make
mistakes to learn mathematics,
right?
So I guess the other
goal of my book,
as well as showing people
all the incredible critical
mathematics that underpins
our modern society,
I also wanted to encourage
people to have a go.
Maths is difficult. But
the people who enjoy maths
are not the people
who find it easy.
They're the people who
enjoy how difficult it is.
It's hard work.
You get it wrong.
But gradually, it will teach
your brain how to think.
And gradually, you will
get better and better
at mathematics.
So I will be around
physically here signing books
if you want to get
one afterwards.
This video will end
up on the internet.
If you're watching
it on the internet,
you can order it from--
that is not a
mistake in the URL.
It only works if you put
the dot in the wrong spot,
because I think I am hilarious.
Actually, Penguin
were like, but it
doesn't work if you put the--
and umble-pi.com doesn't work.
And I'm like, yeah, people
have to earn the book.
And they're like, we don't think
you've understood marketing,
Matt.
So I will also be around
signing books and calculators.
At this point,
though, I am done.
Thank you so much
for your patience.
for making that work.
[APPLAUSE]
Bye-bye.